sarath has been driving a three-wheeler
taxi for the last 26 years his earnings
paid for this house educated his
children and left enough for saving
today he's struggling to make ends meet
his latest electricity bill is three
times of what it was eight months ago
and his income has fallen drastically
people don't have money have we got five
hires in the past now it's about two
even this is difficult everything is
very expensive once we buy food there's
nothing left
tens of thousands of Sri Lankans are
facing the same struggle in 2022 Sri
Lanka's economy collapsed 13 Now power
Cuts fuel shortages and cues to buy
Essentials were common
public anger focused on politicians who
were blamed for mismanaging the economy
and Corruption
the government approached the
international monetary fund for help but
that came with conditions higher taxes
and interest rates a devalued rupee and
an increase in the price of utilities
the costs for Sri Lanka are too high
already for example Urban poverty has
tripled
about a third of Sri Lanka's households
are food insecure
uh so this is a situation where people
are already struggling
and barely surviving in some instances
so to impose further austerity during
this period
it's unimaginable the government insists
that the IMF program is the only way out
of the current crisis
the agreement will be tabled in
Parliament and a vote held to see who
supports it and who doesn't everyone
will have to take a stand the main
points will be adopted as law
the opposition National people's power
Alliance has campaigned against the
agreement saying it will drag Sri Lanka
further into debt
we lost our economic Serenity and
autonomy a long time ago the agreement
with the IMF just strengthens that
position
MF says it's doing its best to help
there are no easy solutions but that's
where everyone must come together to
tackle this enormous problem analysts
say the government's allocation of just
0.6 percent of GDP for social protection
schemes is inadequate
critics say the bailout program sets
unrealistic targets for Sri Lanka most
people are already struggling to afford
basic Goods they say government and IMF
calls to cut back on spending unite and
help the less fortunate are insulting
minnow Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo